[Music]
everyone this is Steve Elantra with
Collider and I am here at the Collider
studio at the Kia Telluride supper suite
at Sundance with everyone behind Uncle
Frank hi Steve hi Steve are you guys
doing very good good good I want to
start with congratulations on the movie
I have so many things that I want to
talk about but there's an ongoing thing
that I do with Paul which you might not
realize which is every time I see him I
bring up what do I have to do to get a
sequel to Master and Commander you have
to find about 150 million dollars right
if I did it on Kickstarter would you do
it thousand percent okay I mean so would
Russell's thousand percent I just want
to point out for all the people that
have never seen Master and Commander it
is a masterpiece I cannot say enough
good things about the film if it comes
on cable I am pulled in every time that
that's all I have and the interview is
over
ladies and gentlemen Uncle Frank
sometimes you get lucky jumping into why
I get to talk to you guys today I want
to start with congrats on the movie but
I want everyone watching this thing no
one will have seen it yet this interview
so I hate asking the generic question
but could you sort of like how have you
been describing the film to friends and
family ultimately it's a film about
healing and about how it's about a
character who is is living with a really
really bad early life trauma and also
keeping his sexuality and his true
identity hidden from his family and he
sort of over the course of the movie has
to confront both and really go through
hit rock bottom and before he can start
to heal so that's that's my you know
high-concept the last I believe it's
been 13 years since [ __ ] am I wrong
I I didn't know if it had been that long
but that makes sense
12 12 so my question is were you listen
it takes a lot to make a movie that the
time commitment everything about it were
you thinking about making a film before
this one or was it sort of like you've
you know what I mean like what led that
little break in time of not making a
feech
since then and what was it about this
material that said you know I really
have to make this well I I write a lot
of screens screenplays on spec and I
have a stack of them sitting around that
I've written that I'd love to get made
at some point or another what happened
after [ __ ] is True Blood and that
took a that took up six or seven years
of my life and then and then it took the
next amount of time for this to come
together because it's hard to get a
movie made especially the kind of movies
I want to make which are small and about
humans and and you know just not it's
not as easy to get those movies made as
it was say 20 years ago 100% I'm hoping
with all of these streaming channels
that more and more like you know I would
use the term indie cinema you knowing
smaller stories can be made and told but
that's just my thing look for all three
of you I would imagine that you look at
a bunch of scripts and what was it about
this material for each of you that said
oh I need to be in this well it's it's
it's beautifully written the dialogue is
sparkling and but moreover it's it's is
beautifully wrought you know there're
there's a great turn in the third act
that you just don't see coming and I'm I
I fell in love with the script and also
I really liked the idea of playing this
man who has as compartmentalised his
life so he has a happy life where he is
out and in a loving relationship in New
York City where he's a professor of
literature and yet when he goes back
home he has a closeted life with his
family and feels a lot of shame
surrounding his identity and I also love
the notion that his niece who he's
supposed to be a mentor or a guide to is
actually the person who guides him to a
place where he can unite the two parts
of his life and there was a whole happy
rounded human
in a loving relationship everywhere how
was that it was great oh good
you'll go okay well I really loved the
script I loved the cast and I just
thought it'd be such a not like great
opportunity to be a part of it and I
really loved the character I mean I
really loved the relationship with her
uncle and even though she does help him
a lot that her main role is just to
watch and tell the story and I feel like
it's just such a different way of acting
and just such an amazing role just to
not be the center of tension it's mainly
even though she does help her the main
center of tension is Uncle Frank and
being a narrator you get to really tell
the story for the director kind of tell
their their vision instead of you know
interpretating and making it your own
character I get to really really help
tell the story of how it is so well for
me apart in addition to whatever Paul
and Sophia said for roles roles for
minority groups do not come off in my
way and when they do it's about a
terrorist and about people marginalized
people who live in Afghanistan where the
white guy comes and conquers the whole
thing so to me that's not really very
interesting as an artist I prefer to do
something that talks about the human
condition and about people who have a
story who have a dream who have an
objective in their life and in this case
like I liked Wally just because he was
an immigrant from Saudi Arabia who was
Muslim
and who was who practices his religion
and yet he's homosexual and he's in love
with this man and he wants to create a
fabulous life for them so to me that was
refreshing and and they're very
interesting in his relationship with his
family and his relationship with Frank
and how he wants Frank's family to be
his
family I mean actually the part is very
layered it's not just like this sweet
guy who was there for Frank all the time
you know if you see it there's there's a
lot of nuances and details and the
performer and the role sorry the way the
roses they're always originated and and
I sort of you know was attracted to that
and that means something and it has
value and that's important to me as an
actor of a minority group for that to
come across
I actually I agree with everything you
said when I was watching it I realized
how help infrequent I see a role like
Wally in a movie and I really want to
commend you on your work because I
thought that the relationship between
the two of you was so beautiful and that
honest and you guys were great together
awesome just but one of the things is
that uh I'm always curious about editing
I'm sorry I'm gonna ask a director
question because it's ultimately the
final rewrite and I'm curious how did
the film change at all in the editing
room from what you envisioned when you
were actually making it it changed it it
didn't change in a big fundamental way
but it got tighter it got shorter the
the opening part of it got much more
condensed so that we we would get on the
road faster we played around with a lot
of different things in terms of the the
sequencing of the flashbacks and telling
the backstory of what Frank went through
as a child not a child but as a young
man but ultimately it's it's very close
to the film that I wrote it's just
shorter and tighter and maybe we lifted
some scenes here and there but uh but I
I love editing it is the final rewrites
and and I it's it's interesting coming
from TV cuz in TV you know you edit
something for four days and you're done
and so I I started working with the
editor on this and in two weeks in I was
like well I think we're done and he just
sort of looked at me like no I don't
think we are so it was a little bit of a
learning curve for me
remembering what it's like to edit a
movie as opposed to edit television one
of the things that I really enjoyed
about this film is that it's tackling
subject matter that I think movies like
this need to constantly be made just
like I'm not I don't mean to compare
these two genres but almost like world
war ii movies things that constantly
show the struggle that people have gone
through that homosexuals and and you
know like the the trials and it and even
though a lot has changed it still hasn't
changed you know and so could you talk
about like the importance of making
movies like this and telling stories
like this to you know hopefully use art
to change people's minds well I never
wanted to set out I never wanted to make
a movie that's like hey America you know
it's okay to be gay because malaika
given to me and living and living in my
life but then I you know I get online
yesterday and I read where Franklin
Graham the son of Billy Graham is
congratulating the Church of England for
being anti-gay and it's like it still
goes on kids still get kicked out of
their homes by their parents when they
come out to them and it's not just about
gays it's it's about anybody who doesn't
fit the paradigm of what they're
supposed to be having to struggle
against so much conditioning and so many
messages to feel bad about themselves
the struggle to get past that shame and
embrace oneself is something that still
is very very important and I think it
probably will continue to be you know
for the rest of time unfortunately given
the nature of human nature yeah anything
you guys want to add so eloquent and now
I gonna fumble through something I mean
for me you know I have a real I have a
real personal relationship with this
story my speaking of shame my father was
a closeted gay man came out at 63 had a
marriage with a man for 15 years and
when that man died he'd my
father who's getting to the end of his
life was was very very scared that he
wasn't going to get into heaven as a gay
man where am i if in his head my my my
brother was waiting for him so he went
back in the closet and absolutely denied
his sexuality to everybody including me
who had you know and it that that's I'm
sure strikes everybody is very sad and
so I do think it's a pertinent issue to
talk about and and the other thing that
I think that Alan was saying which I
hadn't thought of he said there aren't
many films where the two gay characters
in the movie get to live happily ever
after just doesn't usually work out that
way
I mean there's always a victim you know
somebody dies at the end
oh it's tragic you know because they're
not perceived as like just normal people
it's the other nurse you know we get
other Dom how every marginalized group
whether you're gay
immigrant black transgender you name it
you know you know I agree I think one of
the things watching the movie and this
is not a spoiler but they're in the
south and there's a just a one line and
it struck me how I just forgot that
about how we need to be careful we could
be locked up and it's that one line and
I just I didn't even think about it
because you know I we live now in this
day and age where I don't think that's
even possible
but you know just a short time ago in in
other countries you can be locked up
it's very very disturbing you know what
I get acute it - not just locked up
executed it's I mean right now in some
countries you could be executed for
being gay you could be executed for just
going out with it with
without a man next to you if you're a
woman I mean there are like horrible
things sometimes you hear about then
just like seriously like medieval so
medieval in so many ways yeah I want to
I want to flip it so we can just have a
little bit more smiles and uplift but I
was going to say that you know because
we got jokes right movies actually
really funny no I actually talked about
the fact that like you have a an
incredible cast and those family scenes
you it's like a murderers row of talent
in these scenes so talk a little bit
about putting these talked about the
other cast members and just how much
talent you brought to this film well the
other cast members including Stephen
rude margo martindale Louis Smith Judy
Greer Steve Zahn Jane MacNeil Jane
MacNeil it was just it was one of those
instances where casting was seem sort of
blessed because I would send the script
to people through their agents and and
you know these were my top choices and
and I'd get a phone call or a email
saying they're in and it just sort of
happened I had worked with Steven rude
before I had worked with Louis Smith
before but not everybody else and the
fact that they really really wanted to
play these roles you know in this small
little independent movie was was such a
joy for me and such a gift and it was so
much fun to work with them because
they're all so good you just sort of
point the camera at them and let them go
completely yeah do you guys want to
share maybe like for each of you guys
maybe share a day or two that you'll
always remember from filming this
whether it be because of something wrong
that happened or just a great day on set
or you know just a good story good at
this they're very good at those well I
did like all the scenes when we were in
the family house because I mean that
house was like almost abandoned my am i
right am i remember this right but they
like fixed it up for this last day of us
you know to shoot and
it looked like a real house and everyone
there all the actors there it almost
felt like oh this is an actual family
but so it's just kind of you know one
last time this actor is pertained to me
a family was it was very uh it was great
I loved it just maybe that makes sense I
don't know it totally does
laughing hysterically with Steve Zahn
over the body of Steven root and and not
me he's so funny just in his bones and
she's not being able to keep my [ __ ]
together because he is so funny
and then suddenly Alan calls action and
then you know Steve's on just is it's
transformative what he doesn't that
scene I'm not remembering really bitter
and jealous of him he was that that he
was able to be that extraordinary after
just messing around and totally ruining
my close-up by making me laugh last
question I think you probably know what
I'm gonna ask you which is uh where are
you in shooting one division and what
are you exploiting Atlanta right where
are you in the shooting process and what
do you thing I've heard about the
project sounds so interesting and
different than anything that's come
before in the MCU and I wanted to know
if you could sort of a like talk about
that and maybe what excites you to share
with the fans I can of course talk about
I mean it's I so admire Kevin Feige and
the courage that he has what the the
decision he's made with this show is so
bonkers quite frankly and rear and
really risky and really new and unlike
anything they've ever done and it has
been it has really been I think I speak
I'm going to speak for Lizzie which
I guess you wouldn't mind it I think
it's been one of the the highlights of
my career as is making this show we have
I don't know how it's going to come out
but it's been so much fun to to make and
the writings just extraordinary I mean
Jackie Schafer is the head writer on and
she's just been brilliant and
everybody's it's the happiest set I've
ever been on
I just want to actually do one follow up
we've all seen the image of you guys in
like a sitcom in the 50s and what what
is it like filming an MCU that's like on
a sitcom stage sort of do you know what
I mean I've realized that I've wasted my
entire life and all I want to do is be
in sitcoms that's but those there is
people won't have to wait very long fans
what I'm not gonna have to wait very
long to get a much bigger insight into
what the show is gonna look and feel
like I can't say much more about that
but something will be happening very
soon is it related to the Super Bowl
I couldn't possibly I couldn't possibly
say I mean that's getting one of those
ads there's a lot of money I don't sure
Disney has that kind of that that's
that's very true my last thing though
but where are you in the filming process
are you halfway through are you almost
done I'm in Atlanta great answer um
sincerely and I really mean this
Congrats on the movie I'm so happy you
guys made this and I hope everyone who's
watching this will see it and I is it is
it an acquisition title here or is it
have distribution or that's that's to be
determined I will leave it there and not
pressure you on that thank you all so
much and have a fantastic Sundance and
thank you thank you huge thank you to
Kia for being an awesome sponsor and
letting us be here thank you very much